as you heard the next stage in mourning
for the queen begins in a few hours her
coffin will remain at buckingham palace
overnight tomorrow a procession will
bring the queen to westminster hall to
lyon state until her funeral holly
williams is outside buckingham palace
where a crush of mourners is causing
some problems holly good morning
good morning since the queen died on
thursday crowds have been flocking here
to buckingham palace bringing with them
flowers cards drawings made by their
children and other tributes some people
have been in tears all here to remember
their late beloved queen the authorities
have actually asked people to stop
leaving soft toys and other
non-biodegradable items including
paddington bears those are being piled
up because of the video the queen
famously made earlier this year for her
jubilee celebration with paddington
happy jubilee man
and
thank you
for everything
that's very kind
you can see that the police have set up
these barricades to funnel people past
the palace and avoid overcrowding but
this is nothing compared to what we'll
see beginning tomorrow when the queen's
coffin will move down this road through
central london and to westminster hall
and we actually saw a rehearsal for that
earlier this morning the queen will lie
in state for up to four days and around
750 000 members of the public are
expected to line up with weights of up
to 30 hours to pay their last respects
they'll have around ten thousand police
officers on the street every day police
say it will be a massive challenge but
they've been preparing for this for
years
tony
preparing even practicing there amazing
footage of the rehearsal holly thank you
very much